I have a question what's the biggest
fight you guys have ever gotten into
like what did you have you I mean maybe
I'm going into some really deep
territory here but have you ever moved
out have you guys ever broken up in that
way I had one moment and I was sitting
there in the watching TV and I turned
around to look in this room from the
couch and imagine there's no tables or
anything in here she's in the middle of
this thing staring into this mirror
mm-hmm and I could tell she was on her
way out yeah that's because in the
beginning when we first started dating
he didn't know how to properly he didn't
know how to not hurt my feelings like he
would text women things like I want a
raw dog and then lend me his phone right
after and I'm like wait a second this
hurts me you didn't know you know I had
to be very clear with him I'm like look
whatever agreements you've had in your
previous relationship this [ __ ] won't
fly here this hurts me yeah and so and
the other other other big fight we got
into is because we have a neighbor who's
been inappropriate with me and the
elevator
what and Bobby does a Disney hello to
him every time okay no stop stop stop
don't say hi to that guy I [ __ ] hate
him he groped me in an elevator and he
does he come to my show tonight
Annie okay all right and I'm gonna just
say this all right you're right it's
[ __ ] up yeah but my neighbor next door
right is he's a fan somebody he's a
fancy he's a fan
yeah that's why he doesn't he's I'm not
gonna say that what band but he is the
DJ right of a gigantic band yeah you
lost me at DJ when he does like the
sound and all that stuff right yeah
here's the thing is is that so he did
that to her right think he rubbed
against her his hand against her whole
body no he's very
that I long time and so whenever I see
him I don't know what to do so he comes
out like I'm a 12 year old boy yeah hey
what's up come to my show why don't you
and I wait outside your apartment I went
together for him he would destroy us
really yeah not true he's I think I I
have my money on on you guys if I don't
want to fight anybody right now we have
Tyler with us oh [ __ ] yeah
[Music]